- Was that your TikTok, TikTok dance?
- A little bit.
I'm gonna show you a
little bit more though.
I got, I got a little
bit more to show you,
but that was just a preview.
- That was a preview.
- Oh yeah.
- An apertif, okay.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So what is your go to dance move?
- My go to dance move is
a little like a hoedown,
but I didn't mean for
it to be a hoedown move.
I thought it was really awesome.
- Unintentional hoedown.
- Unintentional hoedown and
it got me through the 1980s,
Kelly Clarkson
(laughing)
- The whole 80s.
- You were a babe.
Yeah, but every dance floor,
there's my brother's wedding video,
You could see my tall head
'cause I'm taller than everybody
going up and down in the background.
I'm like, I know what I'm doing,
I'm doing my hoedown.
- Oh my God, can I see it?
- Yeah, do you want me
to do it right here?
- I really do again.
- Again, got me through the 80s.
Five, six, seven, eight.
(hoedown music)
(audience cheering)
What?
Little kick, kick, kick.
One, two, three, four.
- It's like a workout.
(audience applauding)
(laughing)
That's a workout.
- It is kind of a workout,
I'm out of breath.
- I know, I'm like, I
gotta be real with you
anytime I'm somewhere,
like we were on tour and
it was like my last tour,
we were in Vegas and it was
like, we're gonna go dancing.
And literally I went from like my twenties
to like really getting it to like, yeah.
I was like, I love this song.
(laughing)
I was like.
- Little movements.
- I was like, I don't
want to move too much.
- You know, I didn't realize
the power of less is more.
- Yes.
- Back then, you know
that just a little bit of,
- I don't think I still
understand that power Jane Lynch.
(laughing)
- Oh, Kelly Clarkson, I
have so much to teach you.
- It's a lie, grasshopper.